"Stranger Things 4" Vol. 1 ends with
a massive cluster of cliffhangers.
Vecna's identity is revealed, but he
still hasn't unveiled the extent of
his master plan – and he's also far from
the only threat out there. Fortunately,
answers are just around the corner in the
super-sized final episodes of "Stranger Things 4."
"He's not going to stop – not
until he's taken everyone."
After keeping a demogorgon at bay with nothing
but a lit torch and sheer intimidation,
Jim Hopper has had a weapons upgrade, and
he looks like he's handling it just fine.
Cutting through at the 1:30 mark of the trailer,
the heroic Hopper stands tall wielding what looks
to be a sword cool enough to make Conan the
Barbarian jealous. His specific location isn't
that clear, but chances are he's still in Russia
searching for a way home. In the grand scheme of
things, it's an interesting weapon of choice for
the former lawman, especially considering the fact
that everyone else in the trailer is tooling up
with shotguns and flamethrowers – go nuts, Murray.
Hopper himself also wields a gun elsewhere in the
trailer. This suggests to us that Hopper is likely
facing off against some human opposition in this
shot, rather than the Upside Down's hardier stock.
With that said, in a show that's made
Dungeons and Dragons an unofficial guide
to battling supernatural forces, it makes
sense that someone is finally going to get
a sword to do some damage. Who better than
Eleven's fatherly knight in shining armor?
Vol. 2 of "Stranger Things 4" will
undoubtedly lead Eleven to go for a
rematch against Henry Creel, aka the horrifying
slasher villain Vecna. The only question is,
whose turf will it take place on? We can't say
for sure, but the trailer offers tantalizing
hints that Eleven will be returning home —
both in the right-side-up and the upside-down.
Judging by the latest teaser, we see Eleven out
in the open air, away from the test facility she
was confined to in Vol. 1. We also get a final
glimpse of El returning to where it all began:
the Creel home. Has she come to save Max, Lucas,
and Erica, who look to have headed there as well?
Or is this the final showdown that will close the
door on Vecna for good? Place your bets, folks.
Just in case Jim Hopper and company aren't having
a miserable enough time with just one demogorgon,
Vol. 2 of season 4 sets them up against
more than one invader from the Upside Down.
Toward the end of the trailer, viewers are
treated to a brief shot of a demodog tearing
through the corridors of the Russian
prison, apparently chasing Hopper.
Familiar from the second season of "Stranger
Things," the demodogs are the second-to-last
development stage of the demogorgon. While
they're significantly smaller and weaker
than the adult creature, they're still highly
dangerous and can do a lot of damage, as poor
Bob Newby and a whole bunch of lab workers found
out during the second season of "Stranger Things."
Unless it somehow turns out to be
Dustin's semi-friendly former pet,
Dart, the presence of a demodog in the
prison is highly concerning. After all,
it means that the adult demogorgon isn't the
only one in the complex. Will this be the sole
demodog in there, or will Hopper, Joyce, and
the others have to deal with an entire pack?
The back half of the trailer really ramps up
the action, and includes a surprising moment in
which Lucas throws a solid punch at his teammate
Jason in an attic drenched in blue light. It's not
surprising that these two have finally come to
blows, since Lucas disagrees with the way Jason
and the rest of the jocks are hunting Eddie
and the rest of the Hellfire Club in Vol. 1.
Although Lucas tries to expand
his social circle in Season 4,
it's great to see him stay loyal
to his true friends. Hopefully,
Lucas beating Jason is the bully's
comeuppance for his arrogant behavior.
It looks like the fight takes place
in the attic of the Creel house,
an important place the gang has already visited
to look for clues about Victor Creel and Vecna.
Clearly, this is going to be a
key location in the final battle,
because the trailer also shows Eleven screaming
in the Upside Down's version of the house.
Okay, it's time to talk about Nancy Wheeler and
Steve Harington. It's very clear in Vol. 1 that
Nancy isn't sure whether she wants to continue
her relationship with Jonathan because of the
huge distance between them now that he's living
in California with Joyce, Will, and Eleven.
But while she's mulling all this over, she starts
getting closer with Steve again... Interesting.
The new trailer shows off a couple of moments
with Nancy and Steve making their way through
the Upside Down, and it's clear they're trying to
keep each other safe. It's entirely possible that
they'll get together in Vol. 2, and honestly we're
kind of rooting for it at this point — with one
key reservation. Although they do make an adorable
couple, their love connection definitely spells
danger for the duo. "Stranger Things" never lets
us off with an uncomplicated happily ever after.
Robin delivers a particularly foreboding
line at the end of the trailer when she says
she has a terrible feeling that "it
might not work out for us this time."
Uh oh — surely that paints
a target on Steve's back?
Thankfully there isn't long
to wait. "Stranger Things 4"Vol. 2 arrives on Netflix on July 1, 2022.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your
favorite movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.